War it's safe to say Wars always existed
and always will exist always will exist
always has always has existed and always
will exist I hope not you think it
always will there will always be
War this question if is how much war and
and um you know what you know there
there's sort of the scope and scale of
War but to to imagine that there would
not be any war in the future I think
would be a very unlikely outcome yeah
you talked about the culture series
there's war even there yes there giant
War the first book starts off with a
gigantic Galactic War where trillions
die trillions but it still nevertheless
protects these pockets of of
flourishing some somehow you can have
Galactic war and still have pockets of
flourishing yeah I mean it's I guess if
we are a to day expand to you know fill
the Galaxy or whatever there will be a
galactic War at some point ah the scale
I mean the scale of War has been
increasing increasing increasing it's
like a race between the scale of
suffering and the scale of flourishing
yes